we've selected five maps to give you a
small taste of the range of denial ops
awaiting in multiplayer
later today you'll see them playing but
here's a few of my teammates to share
what they love
most from how they were made
my name is brittany vitelman i'm a level
designer i'm kendall snow
associate level designer i'm brittany
perello producer
i'm matt cutrus senior level designer in
satellite a top secret american recon
satellite has lost
power and crashed in the deserts of
angola
with higher dgi forces closing in now
it's a race to secure the crash site
what i love about satellite is the fact
that it's just this amazing natural
space
because larger maps have more components
we can apply more details into maps like
satellite
which make them feel even more natural
the satellite at the center is like a
king of the hill
anyone who wants it has to run toward
you because it's raised higher than the
rest of the map
i'm usually playing one of two ways all
in full ham
dying again and again or in objective
modes i'll flank and get the jump on
people
satellite scratches both of those edges
even though it's an outdoor space the
map's two different regions mean i can
play long
and short range tactics i'll be honest
i am trash with a sniper rifle but a
shotgun
that i can do i have always been a big
fan of close quarters combat
and there is great cat and mouse style
gameplay in satellite
the crash satellite is a super fun spot
to try and outplay radios
predict which way they'll circle the
debris to run up behind them or just
duck inside the satellite and take their
shot
this is going to be one of those classic
black ops maps the world knows and loves
for how quickly engagements fire up
east and west collide on the open seas
in a top secret mission
inspired by a real-life event project
azorian cia
jsoc and soviet forces converged to
recover a sunken prototype nuclear
soviet submarine from the ocean floor
calm waters of armada explode into
massive naval conflict as players battle
for control of large naval vessels with
no
lanes walling you in players can engage
on ships decks
in the water and on vehicles like wake
runners and gunboats
armada is chaos in the best way
this really cool map that gives this
amazing sense of exploration there are
so many little individual areas to find
and new ways to surround or flank your
enemies and get the upper hand
a hidden safe house has been discovered
right in the heart of the ussr
in the shadow of moscow's opulent train
station
with sped snaps dispatched the area has
gone hot
so the moscow map is set in the dead
heart of a big city
so you're wandering through these
streets with a bunch of cars and there's
tall buildings on either side of you
there's this sense that you've been
dropped into a point in history
first thing i do is run right to the
center because that's where
all lanes cross in the moscow map
and eventually it doesn't take long
people are gonna run through
the metro station so you can just sit
there and wait but chances are there's
gonna be people running right into your
line of fire right off the bat
it's a classic three-lane map where
teamwork really makes the dream work
january 17 1984 this location
is heavily influenced by miami's famous
or perhaps infamous
ocean drive this is a night map but one
unlike players have seen before you can
sneak through dark shadowy alleys
go out onto the beach out into the ocean
you can dive in the water
and wait along the coast to get the drop
on the other side
or you can just go right down the street
and bask in the neon light
the first time i played through miami i
could hear this 80s nightclub music
playing through the walls of one of the
buildings
little details make it lifelike and it
becomes this
joy to experience
basically my goal is to never be on the
main street in the center because that
is
sniper heaven and that is britney hell
so i always go and try to flank and get
those snipers from the back
our art and design teams worked really
hard to bring the best
possible night experience to the players
you'll see that play out when you sneak
in the shadows on the beach
or engage enemies in the center strip it
really makes people feel
like they're in miami in the 80s it's
pretty
pretty cool
in crossroads nato has learned a large
soviet missile convoy is on its way to
the border special forces dispatch
alongside mi6
to ambush the convoy and secure the
weapons before all hell breaks loose
it's one of our most cinematic maps with
a boots on the ground field that feels
pulled from the campaign your team will
want to hold down and protect its own
outposts to guarantee access to one of
these tanks
but infantry combat doesn't take a back
seat and crossroads as natural terrain
and foliage
masks movements and provides tactical
advantages there's a bunch of
snowmobiles when you first spawn and
it's a mad dash to grab one
and now running people over with the
snowmobile is my favorite thing to do
each environment changes the dynamic of
how you play
and caters to unique loadouts crossroads
is a bigger map and that allows you to
play
the way you want to play
the beaches of miami a frozen over lake
the open ocean our visual research
department
racked up miles visiting them all
because if you're going to deploy around
the globe in this game
that required them to do the same the
mission for
our artist is absolute authenticity step
one in that process is photo scanning
thousands of real world objects
terrains and materials those assets
ensure our
upgraded physically based renderer
delivers the best looking black ops yet
true 4k high dynamic range with the true
color and tone
ray tracing on systems that support it
photometric lighting courtesy of our
luminaire
system and overhauled contour terrain
system the result is gritty
it's believable i dare say it's got
ambience
most importantly it sets the perfect
stage for multiplayer combat
on that note here's matt with more on
the loads and missions of